So let's see if we can figure out the answer
here. Hopefully the first thing you did was try to
figure out what the sequence of letters is here at
our bottom strand. The first one is A, or adenine.
The next one is guanine or G. Then G, A,
T, C, G, A, and T. Now, if we follow our base pairing rules over
here on the right. We'd see that A pairs with T, G pairs with C, G
with C, T, A, G, C, T, A. And the only answer that
fits with that is this third anser right here, TCCTAGCTA.
The other answers wouldn't match in every place. The
first answer would pair right away T with
A. But, the second letter G doesn't pair
with G. It needs to be a C, so that doesn't work. C can't be the first
position, as we can see here in the second answer. And the fourth
answer starts with an A, not a T, and A doesn't pair with
an A. So hopefully, you can use the base pairing rules and figure
out what the complement should always be of a single stranded molecule of DNA.